[Music]
I went in coming with you I'm sorry
you weren't invited
oh won't you be lonely without me
no there's lots of other boys on the
mission
oh
I'm not in the mid
I'm gonna play a little Hendrix
it does the trick don't start oh I'm
starving
[Music]
I always love this tattoo so did your
brother
[Music]
this was always my favorite seat in the
house well these are the cheap seats
you really need to be more careful make
me
[Music]
do an old Soldier a favor
first things first
foreign
on September 22nd
time for music We heard you this is
gonna be fun
[Music]
and clear
please make Expendables for rated R
there better be violence and lots of it
I want all the blood and guts [__] it
first things first
oh [__]
my mind is full of these beautiful
fantasies fantasies
[Music]
that will now become a headless reality
it's a great idea
well I don't play no more
hold on
you're my [__] kill me you're welcome
now that's what I'm talking about
to be back
[Music]
enjoy the show
Expendables
definitely
rated R
in theaters September 22nd
[Music]
all right